Whether you're shopping for goods
or wanting a taste of local flavor,
street markets offer a special look inside
of the culture of a community.
From live seafood on your plate in Tokyo
to ancient rituals in La Paz,
you'll find something
different everywhere you go.
Here is what street markets
look like around the world.
The Queen Victoria Market is
the largest open-air market
in the southern hemisphere.
Often referred to as
Vic Market or Queen Vic,
the market has been serving
the city of Melbourne
since 1878.
The market even hosts
an ultimate foodie tour
where visitors can learn
the history of the market
and indulge in the best
foods it has to offer.
Once called Tsukiji Market,
the newly relocated Toyosu Market
is a massive wholesale seafood market.
It is most known for the tuna auction,
which occurs between 5:30 and 6:30 a.m.
Visitors can watch the auction
from an observation deck.
The market also features
fresh produce for purchase
and restaurants from the
original Tsukiji Market.
The Jagalchi Market sells
a wide variety of seafood.
Grab a bucket to pick out
your food on the ground floor.
Take your seafood to go or
have it prepared into a meal
at one of the restaurants
on the second floor.
The market sells both
dried and live seafood.
Night markets have always been prevalent
in Asian nightlife culture
dating all the way back to
the Tang dynasty.
When the sun goes down,
Temple Street Night Market comes alive
with bustling visitors and food stands
cooking up decadent street food.
Take your pick from
buckets of fresh seafood
or wander through the
various market stalls.
Though it sits remotely in
the westernmost part of China,
Kashgar Bazaar is often packed
with around 100,000 visitors
each Sunday.
Beyond the souvenirs and trinkets,
you can find stunning silks and rugs,
spices and nuts, and plenty
of street eats to bite into.
A common saying in the area
is that you can purchase
anything at Kashgar Bazaar
except chicken's milk.
This market in Thailand
is one of the most famous
floating markets in the world.
Located about 60 miles outside of Bangkok,
Damnoen Saduak features longtail boats
that drift along the market.
Visitors can purchase fresh produce,
souvenirs, and an array of snacks.
The Mallik Ghat Flower Market
is the one of the biggest
flower markets in Asia.
Flowers could sell out as early as noon,
so vendors start their days at 4 a.m.
Blocks of ice are used to
keep the flowers fresh.
The market boasts an
array of colorful flowers
including roses, jasmine, and marigolds,
which are all used to
make malas, or garland.
Malas are commonly used
for religious rituals,
ceremonies, and as decoration
for houses, roads, and cities.
Discover thousands of spices
at the Dubai Spice Souk.
Shoppers can haggle for herbs,
dried fruits and flowers,
and even natural deodorant.
Grand Bazaar is one of
the biggest and oldest
covered markets in the world,
dating back to the 15th century.
Once a staple of the Ottoman Empire,
the market today houses over 4,000 shops.
Wander through the maze of hallways
where decadent Turkish
treats, colorful textiles,
and mosaic lamps light up the halls.
Authentic handmade Turkish
rugs are a great souvenir.
The Izmailovsky Market is a
hidden treasure tucked inside
the Izmailovo Kremlin.
The market is the ultimate stop
for authentic Russian treats
and souvenirs like the
famous Matryoshka doll.
Christmas markets are a European
staple during the holidays.
Prague hosts its Christmas markets
from the end of November
to the beginning of January
with the main markets
held in Old Town Square
and Wenceslas Square.
The market is lined with food
stalls offering small bites
like roasted chestnuts, chips
on a stick, and chimney cake
known as trdelník.
Visitors can also warm up
with a cup of mulled wine
and shop handmade trinkets and souvenirs.
Venetians rely on the Rialto Market
for their fruits, vegetables,
and other goods each day.
For seafood lovers, the Pescaria offers up
some of the freshest
sea critters in Venice,
many of which are purchased
by restaurants in the area.
What was once a pig market in 1470
is now a thriving corner of Barcelona
known as Mercado de la Boqueria.
Sometimes referred to as
the heart of the city,
the market features an array
of quality meats, cheeses,
produce, and more.
By day, you can find an array of goods
and even snake charmers at Jemaa el-Fnaa.
By night, the square
lights up with food stands
serving authentic Moroccan cuisine.
Ver-o-peso offers fruits,
vegetables, and medicinal herbs
from the rainforest.
It also hosts the Açaí Fair
where açaí is sold and
consumed in its natural form.
You can find potions,
spells, and medicinal goods
at this Bolivian market.
The Witches' Market sells goods
based on traditional
medicines and rituals.
The market's most notable
item is a dried llama fetus,
which is said to bring
good luck and protection.
You'll find vendors
selling their homegrown
and handcrafted goods in the
bustling Castries Market.
The market was originally built in 1891
to improve the town and has since become
the largest open-air market in the area.
Shop the various stalls
or soak up the vibrant Castries scene.
Chichicastenango is one of
Guatemala's most vibrant markets.
Vendors sell colorful
textiles, fresh produce,
and an abundance of flowers
sold on the steps of the church.
Also called Chichi, the market
is only open on Thursdays
and Saturdays.
Cental de Abasto is one of
the largest wholesale markets
in the world with over
2,000 businesses covering
over 800 acres.
Thirty thousand tons of merchandise
go through the market each day.
The market is lined with
colorful fruits and vegetables,
many of which make their way
into hundreds of restaurants
and food stands in the city each day.
Pike Place Market is a staple
in the Pacific Northwest.
The market has been serving
the community since 1907.
Colorful produce, handmade
pasta, and plenty of fish
sold by local fishmongers
are available each day.
Pike Place Fish Market is
best known for its tradition
of tossing customers' orders
across the shopping area.
Watch as they toss the fish around,
or try catching your own.
New York City is a melting
pot of food innovation
influenced by multiple cultures.
All over the city, glossy food
halls with dozens of options
are popping up, like
the Canal Street Market.
Some options include
so-called food mashups
like sushi burritos.